[Music]
the big issue I think is is over the
concept of clarity of roles and
responsibilities you know does the board
know what you know their side of the
equation is versus the chief executive
and that's been talked about in many
different ways you know throughout
boards need to be doing meaningful work
and not be caught up in the mundane and
so it has to be the type of work that
really really excites them and so recent
research called governances leadership
looked at some of the problems that
boards have and they're one of their
grand conclusions in this research said
that it's always not problems of
performance but rather it's problems of
purpose and so boards need to be
constantly asking themselves what are we
trying to accomplish what's our purpose
you know what's the value added that
we're bringing to this organization how
is that different and unique if you can
solve the purpose question I think
people are gonna show up at meetings I
think they're gonna do what they say
they're gonna do I think all of this
other stuff is gonna fall in line but a
lot of it comes down to what's the
purpose I served on a board that
included a number of people who were
first time ever board members the
majority of people had never served on a
board before and so there was a real
challenge in terms of those folks
understanding the difference between
management and governance and this was
also an early stage organization and so
initially we did need board members to
roll up their sleeve and just help
getting stuff done and then as the
organization matured those same board
members needed to adjust to being
hands-off and overseeing and setting
strategy and priorities not doing the
job of the executive director or his or
her staff and so that adjustment over
time was really really challenging I
think some of the big challenges that
board members will face are number one
just kind of taking the time to get up
to speed it's not unusual for it to take
a year before you fully under
and the mission of the organization you
develop bonds with the people on the
board so I think have a long-term vision
about the potential you'd like this
organization to achieve and really look
not only to help intellectually drive
that but to be a contributing part of
the culture of the organization finances
can become all-consuming and they
obviously crucially important but they
also can suck all the air out of the
room and close the door
on other things which can drive the
organization forward so there's got to
be a mix of dealing with the present and
actually planning for the future a mix
of being pragmatic and sensible very
practical about what we need to do right
now to keep this ship afloat and some
exciting and visionary planning for the
future because what's going to keep you
slogging through the hard times is is
the goal of what you're going to do
longer-term I think the toughest thing
as a board member is when the
organization is drifting from what you
want what you thought it should do and
and you're not sure if it's because
people don't care or somebody's
intentionally taken to it somewhere else
or just ineffective management of the
board or by the board and you spend a
certain amount of time trying to change
that and impact it and understand from
it to understand what's happening and
grow from it
and it doesn't go there and and you
struggle with what's your fiduciary
obligation to the group to that
organization and to the beneficiaries of
it not the board members not the staff
but the
fisheries you struggle with what is my
fiduciary what is my fiduciary
obligation to them and and you know
those children and if I'm frustrated
with this can I just leave am i is it my
duty to change things even if I may be a
minority what is my duty that's the
toughest thing I think you run into as a
board as a director of a board